si le hamburger n'est pas vendu dans les
10 minutes il est jeté même sort pour
les frites au bout de 7 minutes
[Musique]
le fast-food une nouvelle façon de se
nourrir à la française avec deux
décennies de retard sur les États-Unis
le hamburger commença à entrer dans les
habitudes alimentaires ou plutôt dans
une façon de vivre le repas familial
n'est plus sacro-saint place maintenant
au repas pratique
pourquoi vous venez manger ici
ça c'est rapide comme service on est en
général on n'a pas beaucoup le temps le
midi
[Musique]
ça va plus vite
c'est bon
c'est spécial mais j'aime pour vous le
hamburger c'est un repas
dites-moi
le repas français bon c'est une
tradition alors justement est-ce que le
hamburger n'est pas un paradoxe
un paradoxe
ça rend un peu avec la tradition du
repas à la fourchette un repas pratique
et si vous voulez un repas chaud et bien
prêt chaque jour près de 1000 hamburgers
sont ainsi confectionnés confectionnés
d'une manière quasi médicale dans un
univers quasi stérilisé et grandement
mécanisé première étape la viande
congelée et les tranches de pain passe
dans un grille secondaire la séance de
garniture les différents ingrédients
sont disposés de façon à gagner du temps
dans la fabrication fabrication possible
de 5 hamburgers différents
au moment de l'emballage commence lors
du décompte
[Applaudissements]
les timer indiquent le minita je ne pas
dépasser
[Musique]
si le hamburger n'est pas vendu dans les
10 minutes il est jeté même sort pour
les frites au bout de 7 minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les deux engagements du fast-food sont
donc respectés restauration rapide et
prix modique puisque le hamburger aussi
entre 4 et 10 francs le client en
dépense donc en moyenne avec les
agréments 20 francs repas donc
économique mais est-ce parallèlement un
repas sain
bon appétit
en lui-même le hamburger et
nutritionnellement bon voilà est-ce que
vous avez quand même une critique à
formuler face aux fast food et bien
cette critique n'est pas à apporter un
burger lui-même mais
à son entourage c'est-à-dire aux
aliments qui peuvent être associés et je
pense que si l'on prend en plus une
frite une boisson sucrée et une glace on
aura une alimentation sans doute trop
riche en sucre et en graisse
parmi les adeptes du fast-food les
jeunes entre 18 et 25 ans et notamment
les étudiants les habitudes alimentaires
évoluent mais les horaires des repas
sont grosso modo respectés et le client
restera en moyenne 20 à 25 minutes le
fast-food répond donc à un rythme
nouveau et prend le pas sur d'autres
lieux de restauration vous venez à
quelle occasion
c'est pratique quand c'est pas le resto
c'est ici surtout pour ça en fait quand
on content de faire des grands sports au
restaurant ça revient moins cher aussi
81 et l'année du fast food en France en
un an de temps les points de vente on
triplé pour atteindre 250 avec la moitié
sur Paris et l'autre sur la province
L'Île en est d'ailleurs un bel exemple
ville de province qui se situe en
seconde position derrière Lyon et avance
Strasbourg ce sont en général les
chaînes commerciales qui ont pris au vol
ce nouveau créneau l'air ou traitement
tique c'est la première fois dans la
deuxième enfin parce que j'avais pas
beaucoup de temps pour manger ce midi
alors je suis venu quoi
non je dirais aux États-Unis dans ce
genre de d'établissement alors je
voulais voir un peu ce que ça donnait
ici en France
ça rappelle un peu le goût quoi c'est
surtout le côté
américain qui me plaît enfin ce qui me
concerne une fois le hamburger entrée en
France il s'est développé transformé en
amour francisé pour aboutir à un autre
genre mais toujours dans le fast-food
entre la boulangerie et le café ce sont
les croissanteries qui constitue
d'ailleurs en France une très grande
part du marché mais extension oblige et
pourquoi pas la pizza peut elle aussi se
substitue hamburger et être du fast-food
simple de qualité constante qui plaît
aux Français et qui peut permettre un
prix très bas
50 à 60 kg de pâtes préparées chaque
matin servent à fabriquer environ 900
pizzas par jour l'originalité dans le
gain de temps de préparation une
préparation et une cuisson en chêne
une fois la pizza garnie elle ne connaît
plus la pelle en bois et le four
traditionnel mais le tapis roulant et le
four tournant
4 minutes plus tard la pizza est donc
cuite et enlevée et c'est là ou
intervient la rapidité du service
on s'arrange pour prendre plusieurs
commandes en même temps et pour servir
plusieurs cures de clients en même temps
et ensuite pour faire tourner les tables
rapidement c'est à dire débarrasser au
fur et à mesure redresser les tables et
servir les clients en vous
[Musique]
malgré les apparences la pizza donc est
du fast-food elle respecte le bas prix
le repas revient en moyenne à 22 francs
elle respecte aussi l'impératif temps le
repas dure en moyenne une demi-heure à
trois quarts d'heure c'est donc un
nouveau créneau entre le hamburger et le
restaurant traditionnel un peu paradoxal
la pizzeria le fast-food qui est
américain et le nord de la France
[Musique]
alors le fast food en France veut-il
dire qu'il y a un véritable changement
dans les habitudes dans les états
d'esprit ou simplement que le manque de
temps est déterminant
[Musique]